these videos were supposed to be about e
but compound interest was the natural
way to introduce it and since i've
already gone down this compound interest
track let's just keep going so that we
so i can put these videos in both my my
mathematics and my my finance playlist
so uh and actually before i continue i
just took the excel and i just wanted to
show you how it converges to e so
this is how many periods i'm compounding
so in this formula
right here this is n right this column a
that i have right here and then this is
essentially what happens when i evaluate
1 plus 1 over n to the n power you can
actually look at the formula
right my excel formula it's 1 plus 1
over
this blue cell to that blue power
all right that's just that formula and i
did it for a bunch of numbers and i just
double the numbers every time so i go to
a very high number very quickly and you
see that very quickly it conjure it
converges to this number 2.7183 and this
number just keeps going on and going on
and that number is e and what's
interesting is in fact you
you go to google
and you type in search on e
they give you the number because google
is actually a calculator and you could
look up e other places and i think there
are sites that calculate e to arbitrary
decimals there's actually some some
people uh who for whatever reason they
see numbers like pi and e they can see
them and they can recite the digits due
to
arbitrary decimal places and i think the
more you realize
the more you see where e pops up in the
world and and pi and and imaginary
numbers i think you'll you'll realize
that these numbers i think they're
they're somehow
scratching the surface of something very
deep i mean we're just touching on them
because they pop up everywhere in
completely different places in the
universe
and and they're all almost magically
related and i'll show you that over the
net course of the next videos i think
this will really
give you motivation if if you're in the
mood for for starting a new cult perhaps
well anyway let's let's continue with
the with the compound interest before
because we need to be able to finance
our cult
or maybe our cult is financed by giving
other people financing
by being loan sharks well anyway that
the the example i just gave was a
situation in which i'm charging 100
interest so let's generalize it a little
bit to the situation where not where i'm
charging um some other percentage of
interest so let's say i'm charging r
percent
r percent
oh my rate right my rate is uh
r percent uh that's that's essentially
what i'm going to charge
so
what is well let me just the rate will
be r as a decimal so it'll be 10r
percent if i were to write it but as a
decimal so for example if i'm charging
25 percent my rate would be 0.25
and i would write that as 25 percent
just to clarify
so what would you owe me at the end of
the year depending on how often i
compounded
well just going back to what we said
before you have your initial initial
principle which in every example we've
done so far was a dollar but i'll just
write p so we can get general
and then the amount that you owe me
after one compounding period is
one times the principal
plus
my annual interest rate so in this case
it's r
divided by the number of times i'm
compounding so that's n again
and i'm raising that to the nth power
and just so this this makes sense to you
in the terms we thought about but when n
is let's say
r
is equal to
and n is equal to two so if if
then this is what you owe me at the end
of a year so if n is equal to two that
means we're compounding twice over a
year or that
we're charging essentially half of this
rate every six months so if you were to
borrow let's say p
is equal to i don't know 50
that's how much you initially borrow
from me
so all this formula says is
after every period you will owe so
after one period how much will you owe
you this is how much you borrow then
after the next period after six
months six months you'll owe me this p
fifty dollars
plus
the interest rate divided by the number
of periods in the year so this is this
is essentially kind of an annual
interest rate but if i'm charging you
every six months i'm gonna divide it by
two so it's ten over ten percent
over five over sorry over two
times
fifty dollars
right
and this is the same thing as what this
is the same thing as 50
times
one plus
our rate
divided by
the compounding the number of times we
compound right and this is this is after
six months as i highlight right here and
then after another six months i'm going
to take this number
and then i you know let's call this
x
and i'm going to charge you
plus
ten percent
over two times x or i'm going to charge
you x times one plus ten percent
over two
and this was x so after a full year i'm
charging you fifty dollars times one
plus ten percent
over two times one plus ten percent
over two well that's just the same thing
as
i'm going to
go in the opposite direction as fifty
dollars times one plus
you know we could write this as a
decimal point one over two
to the second power right i'm just
multiplying this times itself so in
general when i compound and now i think
you'll see the relationship between what
i just wrote out there and experiment
with some numbers on your own if you're
getting a little bit confused or if i'm
going a little bit too fast
hopefully you see that this is the same
thing as this
right
so let's see what happens as i try to
compound continuously or as n approaches
infinity
let me get some space so i said so the
amount that you owe me so we could call
that you know final payment after year
final
payment
is equal to the amount you're borrowing
i don't like this color
times 1 plus
the interest rate
over n
to the nth power
right
well let's let's just let's just make a
substitution let's say that
and i think you'll understand why i'm
doing the substitution let's say that r
over n
well and let's say i want to find the
limit as n approaches infinity as i
compound continuously so the limit
as n approaches infinity
of
1 plus r over n
to the nth power well let's make a
substitution let's say that
1 over x is equal to
r
over n
if 1 over x is equal to r over n what is
what is this let's see that means that n
is equal to x
r right i just cross
and then and if n is equal to x r what's
n
approaching infinity
is the same thing
assuming that r is constant right that's
the same thing as x approaching infinity
or we could view it the same way other
way around x approaching infinity is the
same thing as n approaching infinity
and so we can
make the substitution here
right
and we get
this is the same thing as
the limit
as x approaches infinity
of what
1 plus we said r over n is the same
thing as 1 over x we just defined it
that way
to the nth power but we said n
this substitution comes into this so n
is just equal to
x
r
remember r is just a constant right and
this is the same thing
as the limit
as x approaches infinity
of
1 plus 1 over x
to the x and then when you multiply
exponents like that that's the same
thing as that whole expression
to the r power
right
and this r is a constant right we're not
taking the limit on r or anything like
that so this is the same thing
as the limit
as x approaches infinity
of oh sorry
of 1 plus 1 over x
to the x and all of that
to the r power
and then what did we what did we figure
out that this was
in the previous two or three videos well
well this is equal to e
so this is equal to
e to the r power
so if i charge an interest rate of 10
percent
let's say a charge interest rate of 10
and i want to compound it continuously
over one year
at the end of one year you're going to
owe me e to the 10 power
times the original principle
so we said that this is equal to e to
the r so p times this is equal to p
there's a p the whole time i'll do it in
the blue so you remember
i had dropped the p some way so along
the way there should have been a p here
but it's just a scaling factor it should
be a p here i could have taken the p out
because it was a constant put the p here
and then it would have stayed there
anyway i'm about to run out of time and
i will see you in the next video where
will we know how what what the how much
we're going to pay if we continuously
compound for a year let's see what we'll
pay if we continuously compound for
multiple years at a rate of our percent
per year